a growing network of so-called doctor
detectives is giving hope to patients
with rare and unidentified conditions
hundreds of physicians belong to the
undiagnosed disease Network with 12
clinical sites the New England Journal
of Medicine says the group has solved
132 mysterious medical cases and
identified 31 new conditions Bravo to
them dr. taryn Narula is here with new
details about this network I like what I
hear Tara good morning it's very
exciting good morning the network of
doctors across the country was set up by
the National Institutes of Health in
2014 and is funded by taxpayers for
patients whose symptoms have stumped
medical professionals the group is often
their last hope for years the Miller
family has faced an uphill battle trying
to find a diagnosis for their two sons
Carson and Chase the boys now five and
six have been unable to walk stand or
speak since birth originally they were
diagnosed with cerebral palsy but their
parents felt their symptoms didn't match
up there were many nights when we were
up wandering and why this is happening
and why can't the doctors help us what
else can we do the family eventually
applied to the undiagnosed diseases
network or UDN where doctors attack
medicines toughest cases by offering
families access to cutting-edge genetic
research at no cost
Wednesday's report in the New England
Journal of Medicine says the group has
completed evaluations on 382 patients
and diagnosed more than a third often
through DNA analysis that uncovers a
rare genetic mutation dr. John Bernstein
works at the network's Stanford site for
some of our patients we've looked at the
genomes of all of the microorganisms
that may live on their blood or in their
body ultimately what we're really trying
to do is find patients who are similar
to each other that's really what the
foundation of diagnosis is the report
also says nearly 60% of the network's
diagnosis lead to recommendations
regarding a change in therapy or
treatment earlier this year doctors
found a gene mutation in the Miller
brothers
leading to a diagnosis of me Pan
syndrome a rare metabolic disorder okay
we actually have a chance at helping the
boys figure figure this out like there's
gonna be some next steps here there's
going to be people that hopefully will
be able to talk to you now because we
have a leg to stand on having a
diagnosis now to look at the Millers say
there are no proven treatments currently
available but the diagnosis will help
them build a coalition to fund future
research the more patients you have the
more families the more resources the
better your chances are of securing
funding we've come a long way and it's
through programs like the UDN that I
think is putting some sense around all
of this
doctors say every new diagnosis adds to
their understanding of these rare
diseases and how to detect them the
network can't take on every case but
it's received more than 2700
applications a number that continues to
grow and some hope therefore Carson and
chase and their parents write for
doctors if they can find a cure for me
pan I want to ask you about the other
mysterious illness that we've been
talking about this week acute flaccid
myelitis in 2018 we've already had 38
diagnoses in 16 states what is it and
and what can you tell us about this
disease so this is a rare but can be
serious condition that affects the
nervous system particularly the spinal
cord and so usually children or young
adults can have sudden onset of weakness
in the arms or legs they can also have
trouble speaking swallowing or facial
muscle problems and we don't know
exactly what causes it it may be linked
to certain viruses or even genetic
problems and we diagnosed it typically
by an exam so you have to take your
child to be examined and then usually
imaging where an MRI will show
characteristic lesions in the spinal
cord sometimes they even take a sampling
of the CSF or cerebrospinal fluid being
compared to polio right it's caused and
we think sometimes by non polio
enterovirus as a family that's similar
to the family of polio virus it's scary
not to know what's causing it do you
have any idea why it's happening now
well so we know that there's been over
little over 300 cases in the last four
years so it's definitely not new but it
seems like it's on the rise and we don't
necessarily know why Wow
I'm frightening for the families going
to it Thank You Tara always good to have
you here